the winner of the John Cassavetes award
for the best feature made for under five
five hundred thousand dollars there's
the daddy long leg we actually don't we
did miss like a very important people as
part of this movie graduates and eighty
Spain it's just like I don't know like
sometimes those people just for no
reason when I tell me which was the
cinematographer that I shot with I only
stayed the executive knew sir and yeah
got it without either before and we go
any further it's tough to receive an
award with John Cassavetes name attached
to it that's a very humbling
yeah thanks if my first question for
safdie's is it warm generosity or cold
irony the Independent Spirit Awards have
degree in category four films that are
actually
I have no answer that without
Valarie very valid question I think that
the state of the idea word independent
if some of my hands there's a lot of
commercial catch
more of a genre than it is anything
independence
really is anything is everything but has
nothing to do with money independence
has nothing to do with the sidelines of
the filming exactly it's what the
filmmaker wants to express if they're
expressing how they genuinely feel in
life or in difficult situations or
unhappy situation that's an independent
film for them it doesn't matter if it
was made for over $500,000 or 100
million dollars it's really it's just
about the state of mind if they're being
true to that then they're making but hey
look I do what loves being part of the
peanut gallery and John has it base is
awarded for peanut gallery I'm happy to
be holding this on right thank you thank
you very much
$500,000 would be good to be nice amount
of money to make the producer know and I
just like tried to say that there but it
just seems to the the way these guys
work in I don't know you could have made
a movie like this happening at 10
million dollars because there's
something about the fact that like
you're forced to sneak into places and
you're forced to do them and I'm getting
talk or not the opportunity to light and
it sounded properly the yield of the
CERN is standard in a certain tone but I
think this movie really encompasses and
something to seek the challenge of it
definitely there are secondary search
here kind of benefits and working the
super limited resources that I think
this is a beautiful
unless you have the more creative you
are yes it was an auto-fire of story
emotionally and we tried to stay true
that it was about a father that was
similar to so who tried to imagine what
it would be like in his situation and he
actually had enough such kids it's not
too much older than we are now
I mean I think the benefit that we have
being the age that we are right now is
that we are in between or in between in
general life you know yeah we pay the
bills and have a life reasons were real
people but you know I know how have any
children to worry about
luckily I don't have to compromise on
myself as much as I should if I had
children I mean Casey's got kids but I
don't I would love I love children I can
post a couple times but
it's just the idea that this film is
very much the middle perspective and
we're very much that right now
your to photography you said Brett
chucker which is the most responsible
person I know I'm probably the most
irresponsible person I know Ben's second
most responsible person he thought was
before I go then he's also a goalie and
ice hockey and a drummer and a hardcore
band and they're all very grounding
people in an ensemble and there's a very
grounding courts in the film it was the
type thing where we would be able to
walk into the apartment that we were
renting and like built it out and
everything was perfectly set said we
didn't have to do anything
the lighting was set everything was done
and the kids all of that was important
to the directing because it just seemed
real everything we did seemed like it
was happening in the moment and it
wouldn't have been possible without
somebody really like they're doing so
much so much of this film is its
timelessness like it is so easily be
insanity that could be now set that
yields a timelessness
it was breath that music
that's what we brought to it which I
think it's a skewed part of them thank
you very much
all right
yes right here